what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to do a Super
Bowl catch-up of three trailers that we
did not cover yesterday we're gonna
watch the Super Mario Brothers ad the
Indiana Jones of the dial of Destiny ad
and the Creed 3 spot as well so of
course join with John how are you I am
good sir how are you doing great ladies
and gentlemen first order business go
ahead you can leave a like that'd be
very much appreciated also um one of the
best ways to support the channels check
out some of our awesome merch like who
influences the influencers reject Nation
beanies real rejects oh it's so much
attire I'm really proud of this one here
with the design myself yeah there's
video chapters if you guys want to hop
around but go to shopzeroedition.com get
yourself some apparel of the reject
Nation represent yo
[Music]
all right so the first we're going to
start off with let's check out the Mario
commercial it's only 30 seconds long
let's see what's going on
all the things
Nostalgia yeah thank you for Super Mario
Bros it seems like the only thing you
haven't drained is my bank account
for Super Service call or text Super
Mario Bros Plumbing today oh my God two
nine five five Mario or reach us on the
world wide web at smbplumbing.com we're
making a phone call right now sir let's
see what's going on with this phone call
that's cool that's got to be like the
commercial that plays in the actual
movie but the Nostalgia with that
element yeah yeah no flashing back to
like all the classic like extraneous
Mario media of the 90s oh here we go
hey if you need service please text us
at the same number you just call
92955 Mario that's nine two nine five
six two
[Music]
oh I know mansion and we'll be sure to
text you back
let's go
foreign
that's some great marketing right there
it's yeah great Charlie Day Luigi right
there it's got to be a commercial that
plays in the actual movie before before
he goes into the Mushroom Kingdom is
what I imagine before they get sucked
into there yeah yeah I'm at maybe we'll
see the prologue is Bowser attacking
sure and then we do like where's a lot
of serious and [__] yeah and then it
goes into like guts to Black and then
for the Mario Brothers yeah yeah super
marketing budget that's right I love it
I love it good all right let's see the
Indiana Jones one next
[Music]
that we met my memory is a little fuzzy
once a Nazi always a Nazi
oh
yeah hang up
[Music]
rescuing you and Jesus danger and he has
to go rescue her yeah that's funny it's
funny stuff because it's a version of
expectations I mean Indiana Jones
classic spectacle here liking it some of
the younger Harrison Ford not looking as
good as it first did uh this one shot or
very early on where Toby Jones is messed
up in the background that is it looks
like deep fake it's got that it's got
that weird like it's got a blow around
it yeah yeah it sounds like it feels
like it just had a piece of plastic
peeled off of it and it's like brand new
silicone or something like that yeah
it's still a fun little teaser for
what's to come yeah it's got all the
swashbuckling you could want it's got
you know the the stamp of the time
period it's taking place in you know it
looks like an Indiana Jones movie and it
doesn't look too far out there like a
crystal skull I'm not sure yet if we
should react to it or if we should just
go watch in the theaters and enjoy it
for ourselves and then talk about it
still not sure what to do no right it
depends on if it's uh if people say it's
great you know yeah if it's another
Crystal Skull then we should watch it on
TV if it's a great Indiana Jones send
off we gotta check it out on the big
screen I think it'll be better than
Crystal Skull but who knows if this
movie sucks it'll go get your Crystal
Skull Defenders rising to the surface oh
yeah that's all it takes what have you
done for me lately all right let's watch
this 45 second spot for Creed 3 next
there may have been a time when Damien
had your back
now he wants to take you anymore now he
wants to break it
hey I'm just getting started little bro
I'm coming for everything can't get over
that body muscle Beach
Dodger Stadium
let's draw everything
dude
this one I'm in major conflict over
whether or not we go react to it ever
here wait for it to come out on VOD I
know or go to the theaters because uh
the early reactions were saying I'm a
sucker for IMAX and they were saying the
iMac shots in the box now because I've
always wanted to see that I've always
wanted to see that ever since no one
came on the screen with you know the
Dark Knight films like man be so cool to
watch a boxing match with IMAX cameras
and when I hear when I hear how cool it
is I'm like ah damn that's like the main
thing I've been championing for and I
feel like I might have made my decision
already it's just now
okay so it's fine I'll sit here and
react to it and you go too thank you I
appreciate it I'll take the bullet you
know and I don't want to spoil anything
of quantumania for you guys nothing at
all
um I'm sure but when Creed shows up it's
crazy it's crazy they've really broken
the Multiverse I know I'm saying that
when uh there's that fight tease in the
main trailers yes where Ant-Man and King
are throwing fish the Cuffs at each
other and the way Jonathan Majors moved
there I got pulled out for a split
second it went I can't wait to see him
in Creed yeah yeah yeah yes holy crap is
he ferocious well that's the thing is he
I mean you know he looks scary as keg
certainly but this looks utterly scary
yeah and it's such a rocky style premise
so it's all personal and they have like
you know the the shattered relationship
from the past yeah and then just all
this anger that the Jonathan Majors
character Damien was built up over time
like I I feel like it is gonna give them
a run for their money in terms of just
sheer epicness and emotionality well I
think I'm gonna have to go watch this on
IMAX well maybe I'll decide later but
the early reactions have been like
overwhelmingly positive and I know
that's usually the case but I don't
smell [__] with those early
reactions
sometimes you can read between the lines
I'm like people being pretty
straightforward about how like freaking
epic and cool this movie really is the
Rocky movies had their and downs if
Creed 3 wasn't terrific I feel like
people wouldn't have too hard time it's
too hard at times saying so you know
alrighty guys well before we go what did
you think uh of the Super Bowl's trailer
spots we did not get a little mermaid
cost too much money or something like
that to put out but guys leave a like
check out the other reactions we covered
for the Super Bowl and last but not
least
James Smith I wanna fight you this is me
throwing down the gauntlet it's on man
as Creed is the freshest in my mind but
it's okay because you know we have a
destiny to fulfill we will have to dial
in our choices in this life that bring
us closer together but also closer to
tearing each other apart but then think
about it maybe we meet in the ring maybe
we throw fisty cuffs and realize that we
have a bond all along not unlike that of
two brothers and then maybe from there
we can let all of that anger go and just
go start unclogging people's toilets and
things like that and you know fixing
pipes you know maybe uh eating various
uh you know fungi and things like that I
feel like we can put our differences
aside James Smith and we can walk out of
this as you know a super set of of real
brothers so I hope you're doing well
this month this February and I hope you
know tomorrow's Valentine's Day I hope
you're doing something nice uh you know
getting a little romantic and uh we'll
catch you next month for St Patty's Day
catch you buddy
[Music]